this conversation you don't have to tell
me what she said but it's basically
contradicting what she's saying now
um
ask him there are some things that she
that does not align with things she that
we discussed but it's her life I will
not disclose anything that she said
because we were discussed I was hoping
through a situation so I wouldn't
disclose anything because if she doesn't
want it to be public that's fine but
that's why I was asking her do you
remember the conversation because it
doesn't some things are not aligning you
know this happens
[Applause]
ask you questions in a second okay I
need you this is I've warned you you
gotta go
all right that's fine I'll just go
because this is just feeling a bit like
too much of an attack okay okay
that's fine just go it's fine I'll go